Matthew Knowles celebrates the birth of  daughter beyoncé and jay-z's twins able  to experience bringing a child into this  world if you are lucky and fortunate  enough to experience that I would never  ever take that for granted Beyonce's  father took to social media on Sunday to  congratulate her and hubby jay-z on the  arrival of their new bundles of joy  writing they're here hashtag Beyonce  hashtag twins  hashtag jay-z hashtag happy birthday  along with a photo of balloons and text  that read happy birthday to the twins  love granddad it was so much fun  according to multiple reports Queen B it  welcomed her second and third child with  husband jay-z earlier this week the  twins joined the family alongside  five-year-old big sister Blue Ivy the  exciting news comes after Beyonce broke  the Internet with this shot in February  announcing she was pregnant and quote  blessed two times over  you